bro you've been playing video games for  over two hours so also is that your  second beer this afternoon yeah you are  completely out of control who cares  nothing matters brenda's moving to  philadelphia with scott then do  something about it what's there to do  yesterday i overheard her saying that  she hates me  i hate stephen bro you got it completely  wrong she said i hate stephen's tendency  to take conversations completely out of  context wait she still loves me have you  been hearing me can we admit that only  sad losers play video games yes now go  get her only after i throw this vintage  gamecube console directly in the trash  exactly where it belongs i love to hike